hello everyone it's a revenge time alas
game I lost against Magnus Carlsen age
nine and I'm I'm coming for revenge so
let's get this game started okay I have
the white pieces I'm gonna open up with
E for we have D six I'm gonna go Knight
f3 and let's just see where this goes
I'm gonna go d4 okay Bishop c4 I'm just
gonna try and play normal moves without
trying to out calculate it since I never
know if he plays a great move or or a
blunder let's go Queenie - okay all
right
that is a strong Bishop I agree let's go
f3 engage one just to stop any future
nonsense and probably probably I don't
want to go tonight at five here I don't
mind
doubling okay he's not interested let's
capture and play like Queen if to go for
this h-bond I don't think so okay let's
grab this one Rowley push f4 rook f3 I'm
just gonna roll Queen h6 first but then
f f5 so rook f3 first
okay Queen h6 now and I don't think yeah
he can't do that but it's not not not
gonna help him just capture here he has
to push F the F born but okay capture
capture capture okay let's go here no
I'm not gonna trade sorry let's keep the
Queen let's grab it
okay let's get this H bone rolling h5 h6
and there is it check check and mate
okay I could have done made in one but I
want to do it like this okay so this is
a even beating gauge 9 think y'all for
watching I'll get back to you when I
want to manage to defeat H them